This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. You know when you notice something for the first time and suddenly it's everywhere. My friend Julie Shapiro has a thing for personified teeth on dentist signs where the cartoon tooth often has a smile and teeth of its own. I always notice these now. That and anthropomorphized pigs who are selling themselves as barbecue, that always gives me the creeps, and one day I noticed that sign stores, you know the ones that print homemade banners and posters for you, always without fail, have the ugliest collection of
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。你知道那种感觉吗？当你第一次注意到某样东西，突然间它就无处不在了。我的朋友朱莉·夏皮罗对牙医招牌上拟人化的牙齿情有独钟，那些卡通牙齿通常带着微笑，甚至还有自己的牙齿。我现在总是能注意到这些。还有那些把自己当作烧烤推销的拟人化猪，那总是让我毛骨悚然。有一天我注意到，那些为你打印自制横幅和海报的招牌店，总是毫无例外地拥有最丑陋的收藏，
signs with horrible fonts in their front windows. Now I can't pass one on the street without taking a picture to document the ironic tragedy. Lots of things are like this for all of us on staff, we can get obsessed with tiny little design flourishes. And this is what happened to producer Avery Trouffleman. It was just a shape. A basic little shape. It's rendered in concrete on a building by my house. It's patterned in an office doorway down the street.
橱窗里贴满了字体极其糟糕的招牌。现在，我走在街上如果不拍张照记录下这种讽刺的悲剧，就无法经过它们。我们团队的所有人都有很多这样的经历，我们会对微小的设计细节着迷。这就是制作人艾弗里·特鲁夫曼身上发生的事情。那只是一个形状。一个基本的小形状。它以混凝土形式呈现在我家附近的一栋建筑上。它被印在街头的一处办公楼门口。
Here's what it looks like. Imagine a simple, stylized, four-leaf clover, flattened with no stem. Very symmetrical. I took a walk and I found this shape in 10 different places. It was embroidered on bedding. It was plastered on wallpaper. It was patterned in a public garbage can.
这就是它的样子。想象一个简单的、程式化的四叶草，被压扁了，没有茎。非常对称。我散步时在10个不同的地方发现了这个形状。它被绣在床上用品上。它被贴在墙纸上。它被印在公共垃圾桶上。
You'll see it anywhere you see great Gothic revival building, the Cathedral of St. John the Divine in New York, the Washington Cathedral. You will also see it in domestic architecture in the great, as they're called, cottages down in Newport, Rhode Island. Here in California, it's a hallmark of mission-style homes. You know, it's like a sponge. It just sucks up meaning. However, you want it to be used. This is Christy Anderson. My name is Christy Anderson.
无论你在哪里看到宏伟的哥特复兴式建筑，比如纽约的圣约翰大教堂、华盛顿大教堂，你都会看到它。你也会在罗德岛州纽波特那些所谓的“小屋”等住宅建筑中看到它。在加利福尼亚州，它是教会风格住宅的标志。你知道，它就像一块海绵。它只是吸收了意义。无论你想怎么用它。这是克里斯蒂·安德森。我叫克里斯蒂·安德森。
I'm an architectural historian and I teach at the University of Toronto. And she's talking about the quadrifoyle. This is for leave clover-like shape. There's nothing that I can think of like the quadrifoyle, which appears in so many different forms over such a long period of time. It could be endlessly reinterpreted and re-understood, I mean in some language, architectural and art historian, sometimes referred to,
我是一名建筑历史学家，在多伦多大学任教。她谈论的是四叶饰（quadrifoyle）。这是一种类似四叶草的形状。我想不出还有什么像四叶饰这样，在如此长的时间里以如此多的不同形式出现。它可以被无休止地重新诠释和重新理解，我的意思是，在某种建筑和艺术史的语言中，有时被称为，
as iconographical drift. It's constantly sort of shifting, depending on where it's used, who's using it, what purpose they're using it for. But no matter where it's used, it implies the same thing. Fanciness. Fanciness. Fanciness. Fanciness.
图像学漂移。它一直在变化，取决于它在哪里使用，谁在使用它，以及他们使用它的目的。但无论在哪里使用，它都暗示着同样的东西。华丽。华丽。华丽。华丽。
Fanciness. Fanciness. Fanciness. Fanciness. Fanciness. Fanciness. Fanciness. Fanciness.
华丽。华丽。华丽。华丽。华丽。华丽。华丽。华丽。
Fanciness. Fanciness. Fanciness. Fanciness. Fanciness. Fanciness. the French way if you would like. Cats faye. Meaning four leaves. But the American pronunciation works too. It's hard to know for sure why the Quattrofoil is the global fancy shape. There aren't that many resources on the subject. There's nothing on it. You know, nobody's really worked on it. But Christy Anderson is a good person to connect the dots.
华丽。华丽。华丽。华丽。华丽。华丽。如果你愿意，可以用法语发音。Cats faye。意思是四片叶子。但美式发音也行。很难确定为什么四叶饰会成为全球通用的华丽形状。关于这个主题的资源并不多。什么都没有。你知道，真的没人研究过它。但克里斯蒂·安德森是一个能把这些点联系起来的好人。
I rummaged around and I looked and I just started thinking about it. Now one of the questions is where does it come from? I mean because things don't just usually appear out of nowhere. Christy Anderson says that just by looking at the shape you can see it has roots in Islamic or Morish architecture. That kind of organic shape that comes out of a geometrical form, almost all of them have some kind of Islamic origins, partly because of the great mathematicians who were working on early Islamic architecture.
我翻找了一下，看了看，就开始思考这个问题。现在其中一个问题是它来自哪里？我的意思是，因为事物通常不会凭空出现。克里斯蒂·安德森说，仅仅通过观察这个形状，你就能看出它在伊斯兰或摩尔式建筑中有根源。那种从几何形式中衍生出来的有机形状，几乎所有这些都有某种伊斯兰起源，部分原因是那些致力于早期伊斯兰建筑的伟大数学家。
And the quadrupole made its way to Europe via the Silk Road. The small objects which could be transported with early carpets, velvets and silks that were brought into Europe as luxury objects. Once the quattrofoil made its way to Europe, it was incorporated into tracery, which is the stone framework for big stained glass windows. And quattrofoil shaped stone frames were considered beautiful because the quattrofoil was difficult to make. The fanciness of the shape is because it requires a certain amount of mathematical skill, but also craftsmanship.
四叶饰通过丝绸之路传到了欧洲。那些可以随早期地毯、天鹅绒和丝绸一起运输的小物件，作为奢侈品被带入欧洲。一旦四叶饰进入欧洲，它就被纳入了窗饰中，也就是大型彩色玻璃窗的石制框架。四叶饰形状的石框被认为是美丽的，因为四叶饰很难制作。这种形状的华丽之处在于它需要一定程度的数学技能，但也需要精湛的工艺。
They could have used much simpler forms. They could have used simple diamond forms. You're seeing something which really shouldn't be made out of stone. I mean, it's hard. It's a hard and difficult form to carve out of stone. So it only appeared in places that could afford them, like churches. And because it appeared in churches, this simple shape could take on Christian meaning. Just think of anything in the Christian tradition that comes in a set of four.
他们本可以使用更简单的形式。他们本可以使用简单的菱形。你看到的东西真的不应该用石头做。我的意思是，这很难。这是一种很难用石头雕刻出来的形式。所以它只出现在负担得起的地方，比如教堂。而且因为它出现在教堂里，这个简单的形状可以承载基督教的意义。想想基督教传统中任何以四为一组的东西。
The four evangelists or a variation on a cross. There's a Greek cross with equal arms on all sides. I'm sure people who use the quadrifoyle now will not sit there and recount to you this long thing that I've recounted to you about Islam and metalwork and both all of this. If you google the image you'll find a lot of modern interior designers talking about the trendiness of the quadrifoyle. I was just amazed. I found like about seven interior designers who said, the Quattrofoil is the shape and I'm using it on my wallpaper and all these things. I thought, what do they think they're doing actually when they're doing this?
四位福音传教士或十字架的变体。有一个四臂相等的希腊十字架。我相信现在使用四叶饰的人不会坐在那里向你复述我刚才向你复述的关于伊斯兰教、金属制品和所有这些漫长的故事。如果你谷歌一下这个图像，你会发现很多现代室内设计师在谈论四叶饰的流行。我简直惊呆了。我发现了大约七位室内设计师说，四叶饰就是那个形状，我把它用在我的墙纸和所有这些东西上。我想，当他们这样做时，他们到底以为自己在做什么？
My name is Brooke Taylor and I am an interior designer at ArcSign Architecture. You work to desk away from me. I do. We work inside ArcSign an architecture firm in Oakland. Brooke is designing the interior of a big hotel in Palo Alto. I asked her about the quadriff oil when I saw a picture of a quadriff oil shaped table on her desk. I believe what you saw was an end table that we're using where it's the barbed catriff
我叫布鲁克·泰勒，是ArcSign建筑事务所的一名室内设计师。你坐在离我不远的办公桌前。是的。我们在奥克兰的ArcSign建筑事务所工作。布鲁克正在设计帕洛阿尔托一家大酒店的内部。当我看到她桌上有一张四叶饰形状的桌子图片时，我问了她关于四叶饰的问题。我相信你看到的是我们正在使用的一张边桌，它是带刺的四叶饰
oil and it's basically the shape of the tabletop. Brooke says catriff oil, which is also a correct pronunciation. And her design for the lobby has a lot of quadrophylls in it. Or catrophoils. Here's a rug that we're using in the lobby that is literally overlapping catrophoils. And Brooke actually didn't do this intentionally. I didn't even realize until, well, basically just now, that that catroph table is gonna be on the overlapping catcher foil rug. And close by, there's also a chair with quattrofoil fabric.
，基本上就是桌面的形状。布鲁克说“catriff oil”，这也是一种正确的发音。她为大堂做的设计中有很多四叶饰。或者说“catrophoils”。这是我们在大堂使用的一块地毯，上面全是重叠的四叶饰。布鲁克其实不是故意这样做的。我甚至直到，嗯，基本上就是刚才，才意识到那张四叶饰桌子会放在重叠的四叶饰地毯上。而且附近还有一把带有四叶饰面料的椅子。
It just happened that way. The quattrofoil just has an appeal. It is at heart a very simple shape, but somehow there's just a formality to it. You can tell that there's a history behind it, even if you don't know what it is. You can tell that it's out of history somewhere. And so to then take that and reinterpret it
它就是那样发生的。四叶饰就是有一种吸引力。它本质上是一个非常简单的形状，但不知何故，它有一种正式感。你可以看出它背后有历史，即使你不知道那是什么。你可以看出它来自历史的某个地方。所以把那个拿过来重新诠释
into a modern form, I think has appeal for people. But the way we see the quadrufoil in modern interior design is not referencing Gothic tracery directly. Surprise, surprise. The quadrufoil shape first came back in style in a big way in the 19th century during the Gothic revival period. This was when the Industrial Revolution was in full swing.
成一种现代形式，我认为对人们有吸引力。但我们在现代室内设计中看到四叶饰的方式并不是直接参考哥特式窗饰。惊喜，惊喜。四叶饰形状在19世纪哥特复兴时期第一次大规模回归流行。那时工业革命正如火如荼。
People were seeking style inspiration from the pre-industrial era and kind of harkening back to a simpler time. The Gothic revival movement was also around the time of the Egyptian mania craze, when new archaeological digs were popping up all around the world. It was all very new. It was like, oh my god, they just discovered these tombs in Egypt and uncovering Roman ruins and Greek ruins,
人们正在从前工业时代寻求风格灵感，并回溯到一个更简单的时代。哥特复兴运动也正值埃及狂热时期，当时世界各地不断涌现新的考古发掘。这一切都非常新鲜。就像，天哪，他们刚刚在埃及发现了这些坟墓，并揭开了罗马遗迹和希腊遗迹的面纱，
bringing all those influences in and also reviving some interest in Gothic architecture. Designers were looking to the past and around the globe for inspiration. They traveled, photographing, sketching, digging into archives and collecting patterns, motifs and shapes that they found inspiring. And they would publish these findings in so-called pattern books. In the second half of the 19th century, historian Kristi Anderson again. There was a kind of flourishing of architects and designers who created pattern books of designs which could be used by architects,
引入了所有这些影响，同时也重新激发了人们对哥特式建筑的兴趣。设计师们向过去和全球寻找灵感。他们旅行、拍照、素描、挖掘档案，并收集他们认为有启发性的图案、主题和形状。他们会把这些发现发表在所谓的图案书中。在19世纪下半叶，历史学家克里斯蒂·安德森再次说道。当时出现了一批建筑师和设计师，他们创作了可供建筑师、
masons, craftsmen, really in any field. So it didn't matter whether you were doing painting or tile work. These were encyclopedias of design, of which the most famous one was the grammar of ornament, which was published by man named Owen Jones. Owen Jones was an architect who took a special interest in ornament and pattern. I mean, if you've never seen Owen Jones' books, they are so beautiful. It's a big book. His book, The Grammar of Ornament, has pages and pages of pure pattern.
泥瓦匠、工匠使用的设计图案书，实际上在任何领域都可以。所以无论你是做绘画还是瓷砖工作都无所谓。这些是设计百科全书，其中最著名的是由一位名叫欧文·琼斯的人出版的《装饰语法》。欧文·琼斯是一位对装饰和图案特别感兴趣的建筑师。我的意思是，如果你从未见过欧文·琼斯的书，它们太美了。这是一本大书。他的书《装饰语法》有页复一页的纯图案。
And then, you know, some text intervening, but for the most part, it's just colorful squares of pattern. From buildings all over the world. I mean, you've got India, you've got Chinese, you have Morish, Celtic, Turkish. Like an Epcot tour of Wallpapers. Owen Jones' book transformed the whole way in which design was created, because now you had these patterns which were completely disconnected from their original function. They were just forms printed on the page. Many of the forms across many of the culture's
然后，你知道，中间有一些文字，但大部分都是色彩斑斓的图案方块。来自世界各地的建筑。我的意思是，你有印度的、中国的、摩尔式的、凯尔特式的、土耳其式的。就像墙纸的艾波卡特之旅。欧文·琼斯的书改变了整个设计创作的方式，因为现在你有了这些与原始功能完全脱节的图案。它们只是印在页面上的形式。许多跨越多种文化的形式
Jones documented were quadrufoils. It was particularly Owen Jones' work, the grammar of ornament, where the quadrufoil had a very important place, was part of a number of different pages on ornament, repeated over and over again, and certainly spurred on the interests in this form in the later 19th and early 20th century. And does Anders still use these pattern books
琼斯记录的都是四叶饰。正是欧文·琼斯的作品《装饰语法》，让四叶饰占据了非常重要的位置，它是关于装饰的许多不同页面的一部分，一遍又一遍地重复，当然也刺激了19世纪末和20世纪初对这种形式的兴趣。安德森还在使用这些图案书吗
for inspiration? Number 18 on this page? I mean, that looks like something that somebody would have done in the 60s and... It's kind of matter, no. Yeah. But no, but Renaissance. And it would seem that Joan succeeded in his mission for his book. No matter, no. Yeah. But no, but Renaissance.
作为灵感？这一页上的第18个？我的意思是，那看起来像是某人在60年代会做的事情，而且……这有点重要，不。是的。但不，但是文艺复兴。看来琼斯成功完成了他的书的使命。不重要，不。是的。但不，但是文艺复兴。
And it would seem that Joan succeeded in his mission for his book. He hoped the grammar of ornament would provide context and background for these patterns and that they would be a source of inspiration, which anyone and everyone could use. But today, part of the Quattrofoil's fancy symbolism comes from the modern luxury brands that have associated with it. Many of which are clamoring to own it. Louis Vuitton had a lawsuit over use of the Quattrofoil. Luxury Jewelry David Yeermann trademarked the word Quattrofoil.
看来琼斯成功完成了他的书的使命。他希望《装饰语法》能为这些图案提供背景和底蕴，并希望它们能成为任何人都可以使用的灵感来源。但今天，四叶饰华丽象征意义的一部分来自于与之相关的现代奢侈品牌。其中许多品牌都在争相拥有它。路易威登曾因使用四叶饰而引发诉讼。奢侈珠宝商大卫·雅曼（David Yurman）注册了“Quattrofoil”这个词的商标。
Another Jewelry company, Van Cleff and Appelz, is fiercely litigious over its claim to the shape. There is a power about this simple form, which is everywhere, and yet it has no steady associations with any specific country or movement, and this is what separates it from other ornamental forms like the Flordalee or even the Swastika. I mean, middle ages, seriously, there are patterns from the middle ages in here, and you see the barbed cacti foil. How can you copyright that?
另一家珠宝公司梵克雅宝（Van Cleef & Arpels）因其对该形状的主张而极具诉讼性。这种简单的形式有一种力量，它无处不在，但它与任何特定的国家或运动没有稳定的联系，这就是它与其他装饰形式（如鸢尾花甚至纳粹万字旗）的区别。我的意思是，中世纪，说真的，这里有来自中世纪的图案，你看到了带刺的四叶饰。你怎么能给那个版权保护呢？
The best thing about the grammar of ornament are the pages and pages of beautiful pattern. But Jones' brief introduction is also really interesting. In it, Jones lists 37 propositions for the creation of good decorative design. General principles in the arrangement of form and color in architecture and the decorative arts which are advocated throughout this work.
《装饰语法》最棒的地方是那一页页美丽的图案。但琼斯简短的介绍也非常有趣。在书中，琼斯列出了创造良好装饰设计的37条命题。在整个工作中提倡的建筑和装饰艺术中形式和色彩安排的一般原则。
I imagine most people just skip right over these and get to the pretty stuff. It's an interesting mix of statements in these propositions. Proposition four is almost philosophy, you know? Absolutely. True beauty results from that repose, which the mind feels when the eye, the intellect,
我想大多数人只是跳过这些，直接看漂亮的东西。这些命题中陈述的组合很有趣。第四条命题几乎是哲学，你知道吗？绝对是。真正的美源于那种宁静，当眼睛、智力
and the affections are satisfied from the absence of any want. That is extremely philosophical. And then you have something as basic as Proposition 26, colors on white grounds appear darker on black grounds lighter. But I think Proposition 13 unlocks the logic behind the inherent attractiveness of the quattrofoil. Flowers or other natural objects should not be used as ornaments,
和情感得到满足，没有任何匮乏感时，心灵所感受到的那种宁静。这非常哲学。然后你会有像第26条命题那样基础的东西，白色背景上的颜色在黑色背景上显得更深，更亮。但我认为第13条命题揭示了四叶饰内在吸引力背后的逻辑。花朵或其他自然物体不应被用作装饰，
but conventional representations founded upon them sufficiently suggestive to convey the intended image to the mind without destroying the unity of the object they are employed to decorate. Or to translate. It's basically like don't just put a bird on it. Flurry designs don't necessarily look good. According to Jones, the best kinds of designs imply nature while keeping with proposition eight. All ornament should be based upon a geometrical construction. The quadrifoyle is both geometrical and natural,
而应使用基于它们的传统表现形式，足以向心灵传达预期的图像，而不破坏它们所装饰物体的统一性。或者翻译一下。基本上就像不要只是在上面放一只鸟。花哨的设计不一定好看。根据琼斯的说法，最好的设计在保持第八条命题的同时暗示自然。所有装饰都应基于几何结构。四叶饰既是几何的又是自然的，
but without being too flowery. And this just might be what attracts designers to it over and over again, and keeps it forever floating around us in iconographical drift. never floating around us and iconographical drift. My boys were born in a quadrufoil shape building in Chicago, the Princess Women's Hospital in Northwestern. The whole building is in the shape of a quadrufoil, as seen from above, it was cool looking, but
但又不会太花哨。这可能就是吸引设计师一次又一次地使用它，并让它永远在我们的图像学漂移中漂浮的原因。永远在我们的图像学漂移中漂浮。我的孩子们出生在芝加哥西北大学公主妇女医院的一栋四叶饰形状的建筑里。从上面看，整栋建筑呈四叶饰形状，看起来很酷，但是
according to the people in Northwestern, it was a pretty impractical shape for a modern research hospital, so it's been demolished. A lot of people, including myself, were sad to see it go. A SAVE PRINCESS group tried to get the building landmark status, petitions were circulated, but the effort ultimately failed. But I think it's safe to say that no one would have cared at all if the building was not shaped like a quadruple. 99% invisible was produced This Week by Avery Truffleman with Katie Mangle, Sam Greenspan, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 Local Public Radio KALW in San Francisco and produce other offices
据西北大学的人说，对于现代研究型医院来说，这是一个相当不切实际的形状，所以它已经被拆除了。很多人，包括我自己，都很遗憾看到它消失。一个“拯救公主”组织试图让该建筑获得地标地位，请愿书也流传开来，但最终努力失败了。但我认为可以肯定地说，如果这栋建筑不是四叶饰形状，根本没人会关心。本周的《99%隐形》由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，凯蒂·曼格尔、萨姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马斯参与。我们是旧金山91.7本地公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，并制作其他办公室
of Arxan, a brilliant architecture firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook, all of us are on Twitter, Instagram, beautiful downtown Oakland, California. Radio Tapio. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Arcxan，一家位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的建筑事务所。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目，我们所有人都在Twitter、Instagram上，美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。Radio Tapio。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。